je crois énormément à la réincarnation
et de ce fait là quand je mets mon
costume pingouin je me sens plus animal
que être humain on a trouvé encore
encore plus fou que vous quelqu'un qui
est e oui et oui quelqu'un qui est
devenu vraiment l'animal l'animal de sa
collection et qui se fait même appeler
par le nom de sa collection monsieur
pingouin ah et oui où Alfred
ah
mais on ne vous appelle même plus Alfred
maintenant on dit pingouin vous faites
toutes les émissions de télévision en
Belgique affirmatif on m'appelle pagouin
parce que pour la bonne raison que
depuis que étant un ancien militaire de
carrière j'été réformé et toute la côté
gauche a été abîmé et c'est un chauffeur
j'étais chauffeur de taxi un client m'a
surnommé VI pingouin dû à à ma démarche
un Beaujour il m'a V non
cécunement chauffeur taxi ne se pas sur
ça et un beau jour il m'a offert un
petit pingouin avec la tête qui balance
je l'ai mis sur le tableau bord de ma
voiture et ça depuis le 4 mai 68 et
depuis maintenant plus de 30 ans vous
avez donc une collection vous êtes le
plus grand collectionneur de de pingois
au monde avec 3700 pingoin je 3709
pingouins différents je suis reconnu par
le dictionnaire mondial collectionneur
le watw étant le grand plus grand
collectionneur de l'Europe mais le seul
au monde avoir créé le musée européen du
paguay je possède même des culottes de
dame avec des
pingouins on
veut j'ai quelques sous-vêtements
cochons aussi vous avez là je n'en doute
pas vu votre gabarit c'est tout à fait
normal non il y a une grande le plus
petit fait 2 mm 50 mg il est en c'est un
bijoutier qui me l'a fait le plus grand
Il pèse 60 qui c'est José archambou le
bûcheron qui me l'a fait hors d'un Tron
d'arbre le plus grand il fait
1,70 la firme per quiau des handicapés
qui me l'ont fait pour moi il y a une
grande diversité même des parapluis de
des papiers de toilette dans Max tout ce
qui a les figill du Pingouin j'en suis
acquéreur est-ce que je peux poser une
question est-ce que vous avez été les
voir les vrais pingouin vous avez fait
le voyage pour aller les voir tous
ensemble euh oui je vais souvent en Écon
où on fait les levages des pinguins je
vais souvent je peux rentrer comme je
veux aux EAU à envers tout là il y a pas
de problème sur les banquises sur les
banquises aussi vous non pas quand même
à ce pointl parce que je me contente
d'All gens d'aller dans un frigo mais
c'est déjà bien beau ce costume quand
vous le portez vous vous sentez bien
disons que vous dez un peu pingouin ou
pas Alfred euh écoutez bien je vais vous
dire une chose en temps normal en tant
que être
humain en civil quoi si je peux dire je
suis être humain mais au moment où je
revêtis que je mets mon costume pingouin
il y a une transformation qui se fait
chez moi j'ai toujours euh je crois
énormément à la réincarnation et de ce
fait là quand je mets mon costume
pingouin je me sens plus animal que être
humain et la preuve je mange des
sardines crues avec des sardines crues
la tête les arrête et la queue je mange
des cdine cruez c'est sérieux non mais
ne me demandez pas le pourquoi et je
mange des cerine cru mais vous vouslez
voulez pêcher non je m mais si je serais
enlevé mon costume et é habill tel que
vous êtes vous ça je ne serai pas là ça
va me dégûter et vous faites des petits
cris vous
faites-mi ça là il pousse le bouchon un
peu
[Musique]
loin pas mal que mais je suis content
d'être invité par mê madame du parce que
vous avez même des risques d'allure
parce que du 1er ma ce que fait avril
c'est la saison des amours des pagouins
hein oh et alors et alors le pingouin
est en c'est pas parce que je
collectionne les pingouin bien
c'estement chaud
hein finalement quand même Alfred vous
vous amusez bien je suis en train de
passer le 4 mai je fête mes 70 ans 66 et
alors je suis en train de passer ici
avec toute les télévision que je passe
une deuxème jeunesse une deuxème
jeunesse magnifique magnifique vous ne
SZ croire j'ai toujours dit que tous les
médias qu'il soi journalistique
radiophonique télévisé vous êtes ma
grande famille pour moi je tiens à le
dire parce que sans vous tous je ne
serais un homme méconnu et ça je tiens à
le dire et ça vous a fait plaisir vous
d'être médiatisé c'était important cette
reconnaissance énormément énormément
énor est-ce que quel genre de vie vous
avez eu avant avant cette passion pour
les pingouins et avant d'être médiatisé
j'ai eu le manheur de perdre fa ma
première femme et 5 pé de fillees si
décès sur 2 années de temps ce que vous
êtes en train de nous dire c'est que
vous avez toujours manqué un peu d'amour
vous n'avez pas eu de chance
affirmatif et là je peux vous le dire ça
a servi à ça la collection c'est de
rencontrer pouvoir rencontrer les
autres tarde un peu sur vous qu'on
s'occupe de vous qu'on vous regarde
d'ément disons que c'était une un genre
de consolation pour moi par rapport à
tout ce que j'avais passé tout vous
étiez tous les médias étaient en train
de me réconforter par rapport à tous les
déboirs que j'ai eu quoi si vous voulez
ah
oui pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne
Inna Mireille Duma abonnez-vous et
activez la
[Musique]
cloche